hi i'm sam
hi i'm don't take from anyone we
might be about to be your new boss
if you're watching this video you know
what we do here so we're not going to
try and impress you with a wacky
over-the-top hiring video the truth is
we need visual effect artists at
corridor
digital and we might want you to be one
of them we are hiring for two positions
we are hiring
a cgi vfx generalist and we are hiring
an
unreal slash gear tech generalist it's
really hard to describe
what that role is hey guess what we're
literally making up job descriptions
here at quarter digital
so let's talk about it a visual effects
generalist well it's not that general
it's kind of specific you have to know
cinema 4d pretty well ideally you know
how to use octane your graded after
effects you can put a shot
together from start to finish on top of
that you have to know how to organize
and run a whole vfx
post-production process being able to
break down a spreadsheet supervise the
people that are bringing you shots and
making sure things are getting signed
off the list and approved by the
directors it's not the olden days when
we used to just have a pile of shots and
just try and go through them in order
we're talking about
organizing shots sometimes delegating
work to other people as well as doing it
yourself
this ain't your mom's vfx job but for
real if you've watched our videos you
know what we do here we do a bunch of
really cool visual experiments but we
also do
films we do cinematic pieces we're
looking for somebody that has the chops
to do both cool visual effects for a fun
project but also visual effects
for cinematic pieces that we shoot to
apply it's pretty easy you're gonna send
us an email at cgi
generalist corridordigital.com with a
subject header that looks
just like this within that email all you
should include
are four things three of which are still
images from some of your best work
why stills well we don't want to read
text we don't want to learn about who
you are we just care about your work
we'll have plenty of time to get to know
each other once we hire you and the
fourth being
a youtube link where we can watch a
video of it these shots
and your reel should be work that you
have completed from start to finish
on your own for the second job we're
looking for somebody who is a generalist
in
unreal engine people that can create art
design levels build cinematics and we
have a whole bunch of gear that goes
around that from motion capture suits to
our lights and our cameras that are
rigging and all that kind of stuff
here's the thing with unreal there's a
lot of stuff you can do with it but also
there's a lot of experimentation and
just
generally figuring crap out that we do
here
so if you are good at unreal engine
that's great but if you have also played
around with some of this
awesome real world technology that
combines with it that's what we're
looking for if you'd like to apply for
this job please apply
at unreal generalist at
quarterdigital.com with a subject that's
just your name
followed by this formatting on screen
and the body of the email up to three
youtube links
going to your work and once again this
work should be a demonstration of
projects you've taken from start to
finish
by yourself you might be wondering do i
need to be on camera all the time the
answer is no if you're good on camera
that's great that's a plus but we're not
hiring actors i'm sorry
if you want to apply for this job the
instructions are very very simple but
also straightforward it must be followed
exactly because we're looking for people
that pay attention to detail we
try to be very unbiased here with our
applications we're just looking at the
work and that is it
your name and the work nothing else if
you include anything else we will not
consider the application
also our office is in la so you're gonna
have to move here
if we accept your application but most
importantly we're looking for people
that have true experience
if you are just coming out of school and
you're just figuring things out and
you're just getting started this is not
the application for you
also if you're in another country still
consider applying i'll be up front
it's very complicated to get people in
from another country if you want them to
work here but if your work is cool
enough
we will make it happen we have all the
information down below in the
description we are eager
to check out your work also nico mayne's
ganondorf and smash brothers
dean kind of does ddd i kind of do samus
so if you play smash brothers you can't
play those characters
unless we settle it in a tournament
we're only half joking
to all the talented artists out there
thanks for watching the video we hope
you consider applying here at corridor
we'd love to have you it's always cool
meeting new people
getting some new talent on the team
being creative together here's another
sneak peek on what it's like to
work here great shot thanks sam
you want more sneak peek what it's like
to work here i think you can do better
but i'll give you some constructive
criticism so they can both get better
together
i can't hear you there's trucks outside
all the time